hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
before we begin we want to cover a few
housekeeping items
for any common technical issues please
refer to the help widget located at the
bottom of your screen
this webinar was pre-recorded and is
being presented with a live q a
if you're tuning in for the initial
webcast you can submit questions via the
q a widget on the left side of your
screen
the researchers will be answering them
via the widget in real time
also stick around after the webinar for
the live q a
when the researchers will dive deeper on
popular questions asked
additional resources and links provided
from today's presentation
can be found in the resource list on the
right side of your screen
an on-demand version of the webinar will
be available approximately one day after
the initial webcast
and can be accessed using the same
audience link that was sent to you
earlier
on-demand viewers will get to hear the
recorded version of the live q a
enjoy the webinar
hello everyone and welcome to this
webinar
on post quantum cryptography today we're
going to learn about
super singular isogenys i'd like to
thank you for joining me
and my name is craig costello i'm a
senior researcher here in the security
and cryptography group
at microsoft research and this has been
my passion
and my topic of real interest for the
last i'd say four or five years
uh my background is in elliptic curve
cryptography uh but in in recent times
this has kind of transitioned to looking
at how elliptic curves can be used
to to achieve post-quantum cryptography
and that's what we're going to talk
about today
this is a post quantum cryptography is
it is
a really hot topic at the moment and
super singular isogenys are a way of of
achieving
uh post-quantum key exchange it's
there's different trade-offs between uh
super singular isogenys and
other methods of of achieving uh
post-quantum
or of doing post-quantum cryptography uh
but in my opinion
uh isogeny's is the most elegant and and
by far the coolest way to do it today
we're going to really try to approach
the topic
um from the ground up and and really
just give a high level overview of
of what's going on there's a lot of
details and a lot of jargon
um that can often times be overwhelming
but
we're going to do things by really
walking through step by step
a toy example i'm i'm a big fan of
learning things by example first and
then
chasing the details later and so that's
what i'd like to do
i certainly wouldn't expect uh anyone to
be able to
digest all of the all of the content at
first sight
these are these are things that took me
months if not years to learn
but the idea here is that we're going to
walk through an example step by step
so that you can get the gist of what's
going on
and if you like you can you can read a
lot more about
uh the super singular isogeny
diffie-hellman
and the the now broader field of isogeny
based cryptography
there's going to be a list of
supplementary materials
i believe it'll be over here on your
left and in that supplementary materials
will be the
much more detailed tutorial paper that
this talk is based on
so if you want to follow along with that
paper in hand or if you want to
[Music]
watch the talk with all of the details
of this example
then that paper is where you'll find it
and otherwise there's a lot more
uh detail uh in the supplementary
material there so there's
um there's gonna be tutorial questions
uh and answers
and there's going to be a lot more
further reading
and a lot of other links to other
resources that i'll talk about
at the end of the webinar as i go if
you're one of the people that are
watching this broadcast live
i encourage you to ask questions this is
a pre-recording but i'll be
online when this goes live to answer any
questions as we go for those that are
watching this
after the fact then some of those
questions i'll be sticking around for a
live q a
after the talk and some of those
questions will be answered uh and
recorded for you
i'm going to walk through this exact
example that we're seeing
on the front slide here so um
this is a this is a gif that's animating
essentially
a toy example of the super singular
isogeny diffie-hellman protocol
and the way it works is alice and bob
who uh the the two parties that want to
derive a shared secret key
alice and bob is starting on the same
note that node that alice just departed
from now
they're starting on the same node and
they're taking walks
in the super singularisogyny graph alice
is going to walk
on different edges to bob but she's
going to
she's going to perform her the
derivation of her public key
by walking away from their same starting
node she's then going to stop
at some other note in the graph and
not reveal her walk that's her secret
but she's going to
send bob her node which is the her
public key bob is going to do the same
thing he's going to start at the same
place that alice did but he's going to
walk away in a different graph
in the same set of nodes but different
edges
and he's going to send his public key
which is the node that he lands on
as a result of his secret walk at this
point they both
then do another walk from
each other's uh public keys or rather
from each other's
destination nodes of their first walk
and then
using their same secret that they use to
derive their public key
they're going to land at the same shed
secret okay so this gif is really
animating what's going on there's no
mathematics
happening in this picture but what we're
going to do is actually
dig beneath the picture and and look at
the mathematics that's going on
in this toy example this is actually a
real example
using toy parameters um and then the
idea is hopefully
if you can understand and get the rough
gist of what's going on with this toy
example
extrapolating to the real world uh
parameters
should be easy and we'll do that in one
slide at the end of the talk we'll talk
about the difference between
this toy example and uh
and what actually goes on with with the
super singular isogenies in
in practice before we go any further we
should really talk about
why we want to do this why do alice and
bob want to walk around in this funny
graph
and why why do we want to do things this
way rather than
more traditional methods and the reason
is
quantum computing so you might have
heard of quantum computing
and you might have heard that quantum
computing can do all of these fantastic
things
but one of the things that it can also
do
is it can also solve specific
mathematical problems
and it just turns out that those
mathematical problems are the problems
on which
uh modern public key cryptography is
founded
so at the moment we've got alice and bob
here
that want to that want to
derive a shared secret and that so alice
and bob
uh in the real world can be anyone from
you know alice could be you and bob
could be your
uh your friend over sitting on the other
side of the world and you might just
want to send
whatsapp messages to each other or alice
and bob could both be
uh banks and they might want to
send each other uh you know make it make
a transaction from the other side of the
world
i guess the most common example of of
alice and bob that
that you and i would experience every
day is any time we do a secure
web browsing session and and we use tls
to do
secure web browsing what we're actually
doing is
connecting to a server as
assuming we're the client and so alice
and bob then become the
the client and the server and the idea
is that
they've never um they've never come in
contact before the server doesn't
doesn't trust that the client is saying
is who they're saying they are and the
client doesn't trust that the server
is actually the the server it wants to
connect to so there's got to be this
um this exchange of data that convinces
both the client and the server that they
are who they say they are and moreover
they've got to communicate on an
insecure channel that we call the
internet
and they've got to be able to derive a
shared secret or a shared common value
um that can be used then to to be fed
into
traditional symmetric cryptography that
can then be used to
you know uh either start off a stream
cipher or a block cipher that can be
then used to
encrypt bulk data at a much cheaper cost
so the way that the way that tls or any
of these protocols typically work is
there's a lot of mathematical operations
that are done at the start
in order to derive a common value or
what we call the shared secret and once
you derive this shared secret you can
then
proceed to do to do symmetric symmetric
encryption
the problem is that quantum computers uh
threaten the public key cryptography so
they threaten the
the key exchange mechanisms that are
currently out there that are based on um
finite fields so the discrete logarithm
problem in a finite field
or the discrete logarithm problem on an
elliptic curve
and similarly they threaten our
signature our signature scheme so they
threaten
rsa based on integer factorization
and they threaten the olympic curve
discrete log problem which is also used
in ecdsa signatures so
essentially if and when a large scale
quantum computer is built
then all of the things that alice and
bob currently do to secure the internet
are um under threat and and if a quantum
computer is built
uh at a large scale then it will break
all of the all of the methods that alice
and bob currently use and all of the
methods that we currently use
to secure our digital our digital world
so the idea is
what we want to do today is to introduce
a mechanism that
does the same thing that we've always
done in trying to derive a secret shared
value
but we want this to be a problem that's
not only hard
to solve on on the classical computers
that we have today but also
on the quantum computers that we're
anticipating in the future
so this super singular misogyny problem
or this
super singular osogyny diffie-hellman
that we're going to walk through is one
such approach to achieving
post-quantum security so in one slide
we're going to brush over elliptic
curves which
are the objects that that are going to
be the main objects that we're studying
today
um elliptic curves have already been
used in cryptography for
over two decades um but
we're going to use them in a different
way than we traditionally use them
so what is an elliptic curve well an
elliptic curve
is a cubic curve that we usually write e
over k and you often see what we call
the short via stress equation so it's y
squared equals x cubed plus ax plus b
we're gonna use a slightly different
equation today but where do elliptic
curves come from well
elliptic curves are essentially the
first or rather the simplest geometric
object that offers
security different to say the security
of
the finite field discrete log problem so
elliptic curves are a group um
and we've used these groups to replace
other groups in cryptography like finite
fields
or even rsa in the case of signatures
we've used elliptic curves because
they they offer uh more strength as far
as their
the best known attacks against the
discrete log problem so in old school
ecc
uh what we what we often do is we write
this elliptic curve over a finite field
f q and we fix this curve once and for
all meaning we we
find a a well chosen curve that that has
a a prime or near prime
number of points and we work in this
large primordial subgroup
where hopefully the discrete logarithm
problem is is hard
now our group elements on these curves
are are the set of points the set of
points that satisfy this curve so the
these curves are in two variables x and
y we look at all of the solutions to
this
uh equation over the finite field and
together with this um fabricated point
or this
uh additional point which we call the
pointed infinity this acts as the
identity of the group
so our group is the set of all the
solutions to the equation and this
additional identity element that we
write
uh mathcal of e
and so what is the fundamental operation
that we're that we're dealing with
the fundamental operation is encoding
our secrets
by taking a point on that elliptic curve
and performing the group operation and
or adding the adding the point to itself
end times
and we do that via the scalar
multiplication so
on the right you can see that we've got
these elliptic curves that are these
geometric
things that we can write down and
whether we're in the bottom in the
picture on the bottom right we're adding
the point p
to itself and in the picture in the top
right we're adding two different points
p and q on this elliptic curve and we do
that by
running a line through the through the
two points finding the third
intersection of that of that line with
the cubic curve because a line in a
linear
function and a cubic function must
intersect in three places
and then we we negate the the result or
we we flip the point over the x axis
to get the sum of the two points so
that's how the elliptic curve group
looks and we're going to use those two
um those two pictures or the or the math
that's happening
underneath those two pictures to compute
scalar multiples of a point quickly so
just like in a finite field or in uh
working modular prime
we might uh we might square and multiply
to do
group exponentiations very quickly on an
elliptic curve we say we double and add
um which is the which is the analog of
of
uh square and multiply in a finite field
now the discrete logarithm problem which
all of the uh classical elliptic curve
cryptography is built upon
is if i input the point s
uh which is p added to itself n times
or this the scalar n the the nth scalar
multiple of p
by input s and p the question is what
was the scalar n
and that that's the elliptic curve
discrete log problem and we believe it's
very hard that's why
currently the internet is secured using
this problem uh
but that is that is the foundational
problem of classical elliptic curve
cryptography it's also
the problem that quantum computers are
very good at solving
so if a large-scale computer's quantum
computer's built then
this problem becomes easy but for now
it's exponentially difficult
and uh we hope um we hope
we have been hoping that it's it's
secure against uh classical attacks
one thing i will say is that elliptic
curves are both
uh you should think of them as both
being algebraic and geometric objects so
they're geometric in the sense that we
can draw those pictures on the right
they're curves we can
um we can write down uh you know we can
write down stuff about their geometry
but they're also algebraic in the sense
that we can we can um
we can do group operations on them and
we can i guess
from a cryptographer's standpoint we can
forget about the the geometry
and um work with the points
algebraically
so there's kind of two or three more
concepts we have to
um introduce before we start looking at
the srdh protocol
the first thing we need to look at is
isomorphisms
and jain variants so we might have two
elliptic curves that look different
but they could essentially be the same
thing or they could be roughly
one could be the same as the other thing
but it's just in disguise and that's
what we
we call isomorphic so if they have
this same jane variant then we say two
elliptic curves are isomorphic and this
is an if and only if
so if we're looking at this elliptic
curve e sub
e sub a which is a montgomery curve y
squared is x cubed plus ax squared plus
x it has a j invariant that's given by
that function of a
and so we might have two elliptic curves
like we have in this example that have
different a values
but because they both have the same j
invariant so
one has a equal to 208 i
plus 161 here we're working in a
quadratic extension field of
of f sub 431 or the finite field of size
if these two elliptic curves have the
same j invariant which they do then we
know that they're isomorphic
and what that means is we can write a
simple
uh linear map between all of the points
on that curve so
yeah this this map psi that's this map
side that's written from e to e prime
it takes the x and y coordinates of any
point on e any rational point on e
it multiplies the x coordinate by some
constant value
66i plus 182 it then adds another value
and it multiplies the y coordinate by
some value
and magically you get a point on the new
curve
e prime and that will work for every
single point
in the the group of points on e
conversely there's psi
inverse which will map every single
rational point from
the group of points on e prime to a
rational point
on the group of points of e so because
there's no exceptions
roughly speaking we can we can look at
these maps and say there will be no
exceptions to these maps
provided we we define um the maps at the
points at infinity which i've
i've done on the last line but because
there's no denominators here
we don't expect there to be any
exceptions to those maps and and
indeed that's goes hand in hand with
them being an isomorphism they don't
really have
a kernel beyond the points at infinity
themselves
so we say that they've got a trivial
kernel
and that they are isomorphisms so
basically
we in in sidh in the in the super signal
or society protocol we treat these
curves as being
the same or belonging to the same
isomorphism class
now this is a good way to start thinking
about isogenesis
is being more general maps than than
isomorphisms in fact isomorphisms are
in fact a special case of isogenes
so with an isogeny they are again maps
between elliptic curves
but they're maps that have exceptions
so i've written an example of a misogyny
here
which is this this map phi that takes
points from e sub a to points on
e sub a prime but
notice now that this map has
denominators
so it takes almost
all of the x values on uh
e sub a to a point on e sub a prime
but there's an x value that will make
those denominators be zero
which will uh make that map as it's
written ill-defined
and in fact this is the point with
x-coordinate 350i plus 68.
that point uh the y coordinate of that
point is zero
um that corresponds to it being a point
of order two so that
but that point is an exception
um to that to that rational map as it's
written
and it is in fact in the kernel of this
isogeny
so not only does the kernel contain the
point of infinity it also contains
a rational point in this case a point of
order two
that will that will make those
denominators vanish
and that's why uh we've got this more
general
definition of misogyny so if there is um
elements in the kernel beyond
the point of infinity then we're not
we're no longer dealing with
two objects that are each other in
disguise we're dealing with elliptic
curves that are isogenous
and in this case you can see that
they've got two different j invariants
so they're not isomorphic but they're
they are isogenous
so esogenous is this more general
more general way of mapping points on
elliptic curves
and what we're really interested in is
um
compute computing these sorts of
rational functions
uh the the sorts of computations we do
in sidh
they take the the x and y coordinates of
a point on
e sub a and they do these rational
functions like the one that's written
there
and they output the coordinates of a
point on e sub a prime
you might think uh how big can these
rational functions be
well it's closely depends on on the
number of points that we want
in the kernel of the isogeny the first
point to really note here and it's a and
it's a
rather important one is that the types
of
isogenies that we're going to be dealing
with which are what we call separable
lysogenys
they're in one-to-one correspondence
with kernels
um and in particular these kernels
have to be subgroups of the of the set
of points on the elliptic curve
e so for any subgroup
of points on the curve e there is a
unique misogyny
such that that subgroup is the kernel
and conversely for any given misogyny
there is a unique set of points um
in the domain that that forms the kernel
of that isogeny
uh and it will be a subgroup of points
on on e
so the way that we make this explicit
and indeed the way that that
map um that rational map was derived
is with what's what's called values
formulas so
uh in values formulas you can input the
the elliptic curve e and any subgroup of
points
of the of the points on e and values
formulas will
magically output the codomain curve or
the the image curve e
prime and the map phi that is needed to
move points
through the isogeny now they lose
formulas
the the formulas given on this page are
rather rather simple
that's because there's only two elements
in the kernel there's the point of
infinity
and there's this point of order two so
there's this is a subgroup of order two
which is why the degree of um
the degree of these rational maps is is
two
and in general the degree of these
separable isogenys
is the number of elements that you
specify in the kernel so if we had
uh a subgroup with a subgroup with a
hundred elements
the the the maps here would be of degree
100 and and so on
um and so what you need to
take forward is that the the formulas
are
um to compute them and to evaluate them
uh that it takes time roughly
proportional to the size of the
the subgroup that we're dealing with um
another fact that's really really useful
in sidh is that if you've got
an isogeny from the elliptic curve e1 to
the
curve e2 and another one from e2 to e3
then these can be composed to give an
isogeny
from e1 to e3 but in that case
the degree of the composition is the
product of the degrees
and this is something that we that we
really need going forward because it uh
it allows us to compute what look like
very large degree
isogenes um as a chain or as a
composition of
of many small isogenes and again
it should be noted that isogenes are
both algebraic and geometric
morphism so just like the elliptic
curves are algebraic and geometric we
can
draw pictures of points on curves and we
can treat them algebraically as groups
the uh the maps themselves are also
algebraic and geometric so we can
they map points from one curve to points
on another curve
in the geometric sense but also they map
they preserve the group law on the first
curve
um to the group law and the second so
that last equation on this slide
says that five p plus q is five p plus
five q
the plus on the left hand side is the
group law on e and the plus on the right
hand side is the group law and e prime
the isogeny respects this group lauren
from this you can derive a lot lots of
facts that uh
that become uh useful to take with us in
in srdh
so we'll be keeping it simple today
we'll be mainly dropping
the y coordinate so this slide is saying
whether we're dealing with the
multiplication by n map
which takes points on the curve e and
maps them to points on the curve e so
it's
it's technically an isogeny but it's not
a a really interesting one as far as
we're concerned because it keeps us on
the same curve
it's a special case where the image
curve turns out to be the curve itself
uh or we're dealing with non-trivial
misogynistogenes that move us from one
curve to another
the way that maps are always written uh
the x moves to some rational function of
of x on the new curve
and the y coordinate is just multiplies
by the derivative of that function of x
and some constant so for the purposes of
of this
webinar we're going to ignore the y
coordinate and just work with with x
coordinates and just look at the
x coordinate formulas explicitly and
happily this is also what's done in
practice so
whether you're talking about ecc in the
classical sense
or you're talking about post quantum ecc
with isogenes
um this dropping of the y coordinate and
just looking at x coordinates is what we
do in practice so it's what
the actual implementations um do to save
to save to be faster and simpler um
and the other really nice thing going
for that going forward is that we only
need
isogenys of degree two and three so uh
you saw on the last slide that the the
complexity of a prime degree isogeny is
proportional to the to the degree itself
um the time complexity and so that's why
we're going to just take the two
smallest primes we're going to let alice
do deal with two esogenies and we're
going to let bob deal with three
isogenys
and roughly speaking this is the only
functions that alice and bob need
to do an srdh or at least a computer
misogyny
in the sidh landscape so on alice's side
the only sorts of functions she needs is
the multiplication by two map
which takes points on a given curve and
just doubles them or computes
the image of the multiplication by two
map and she needs two esogenies so she
needs
isogenes like the one we saw before
whose kernel is of size two
so it's the point at infinity and one
other element in this case
it's the the element alpha comma zero a
point of order two on on e sub a
uh and she also needs to be able to
update the
coordinate of the the curve she's
working on this she moves from ea to ea
prime
and she needs to be able to update
accordingly on bob's side
he needs the multiplication by three map
which is this
uh degree nine map that you see
in in blue and he needs to be able to
compute three isogenies so he needs to
be able to
come across a subgroup of of order three
and
input that subgroup into values formulas
the output of that is exactly like you
see
as the second equation in the blue box
he also needs to be able to update his
from the curve that he was sitting on to
the new curve that he walks to the
the curve coefficient which is uh which
is this a prime
okay so that that's essentially all of
the operations that you need to do
to do sidh in the real world
okay so here goes we're going to focus
on a toy example but really the only
difference between the toy example that
we're
working with and the examples that we
use in the real world is the size of the
primes that we deal with
so here we're going to take the the nice
tiny prime
p equals 431 um but in general these the
primes will be exponentially large so
they'll be
anywhere between uh 400 bits and and 800
bits
are the types of primes we use in
practice we always work over
the quadratic extension field for
technical reasons that you can
you can look up in in the tutorial but
essentially
all of the jain variants so those
isomorphism invariants
that correspond to super singular
elliptic curves
all of those js are always defined over
fp squared we never have to extend
our prime fields any higher to to go
looking for
j invariants that that correspond to
super singular
elliptic curves and
there's a theorem that says that
no matter what prime we're dealing with
there's always very close to p
over 12 or the floor of p over 12 super
singular j invariance
and they become the nodes in the graph
the nodes in the super singular isogeny
graph that we're
that we're working with so in this case
p is 431 and
and the floor of p over 12 is
i believe 37 or it'll be either 35 36 or
37 and we're always within
we're always within two of the number of
nodes
sorry p over 12 the floor of p over 12
is always within
two of the number of nodes that are in
the super singular isogeny graph so in
this case there's 37
nodes in the graph and they are all of
the super singular j invariants over
this
over this prime but for any prime you
you write down you'll
always have roughly p over 12 such nodes
and these become the elements that we
work with
in in srdh for alice and bob
the the nodes are the same so the nodes
are always this fixed set
but the edges between those nodes are
different
and importantly they're um they should
be
very unrelated or alice's nodes
shouldn't really
be related in any way that's meaningful
to the way that bob's nodes
um look so alice works in what we call
the two archogeny graph
now that means that at each node
with the with the exception of a uh of a
handful of the nodes here
there's three edges emanating from any
given
node and they correspond to the to the
three possible
two isogenys that we saw a couple of
slides ago
so if you look at any note in this graph
there should be three edges connecting
you to some other
um node in the graph and the reason we
the the reason we believe that uh super
singular arsogenic graphs
a good place to do crypto and not only
crypto but post quantum crypto
is that um they're what we call
expander graphs and they they've got a
lot of uh really nice properties as
uh security properties um
that you can you can look up in the
tutorial sheet for the ex
for the um the mathematical definitions
but roughly speaking what it means is
that there's no way to draw these graphs
um such that the the edges would be
would look any less messy um what it
means is we can
essentially get from any node in the
graph to any other node in the graph
with a a relatively small number of
steps
so there'd be no way to rearrange these
nodes such that alice's edges
look um any less messy than they
currently do any any reordering of these
it should look that messy but what that
means is that you can
with a small number of steps from any
given node you should
uh you should be able to be distributed
randomly across the whole graph
um so this is what this rapid mixing
property guarantees
means that we can we can uh be confident
that as long as we take a certain number
of steps from a given node in the graph
then
uh we could essentially land anywhere
with with reasonably uniform probability
bob's graph again as i said it uses the
exactly the same nodes
but his graph has different edges he's
going to walk with three isogenes
and so at any at any given elliptic
curve or
uh isomorphism class or at any given
jane variant
bob now has four subgroups of order
three
that determines his three isogenies and
what that means is there's
four edges emanating from any given node
in this graph so bob's graph looks a lot
messier but again
there should be no way to really draw
these nodes such that these edges
look any less messy anyway we we reorder
these things
um it's going to be equally as messy but
again these these graphs are all
connected which means you can get from
any given node to any other given node
and as long as we take relatively small
number of steps we we should get a
uniform distribution in our walks across
across the graph and that's why we
believe that these expanded graphs are
offer good security in in cryptography
one more slide before we before we enter
the protocol is in in
coming up with a toy example that's
that's actually real that actually
corresponds to
i guess a toy toy version of the
protocol um
there's some things that look there's
there's some behaviors that look like
they might they might be problematic for
larger parameters but
as the parameters scale these behaviors
go away and one of them is that in this
example
um a lot of the nodes look like they
correspond to j invariants that are
defined over fp rather than f p squared
so they're the ones that
that don't have any uh extension that
then
they've just got base field elements as
their j invariants um
but what happens is as p gets large as p
approaches infinity or approaches
parameters of cryptographic size uh
these become really really rare in the
graph so
as we said there's roughly p over 12 of
these nodes but as p
becomes huge only square root of p or
big o of the square root of p of these
uh are in the base field so here it
looks like more of them are in the base
field than
than ones that are in the extension
field but this is just an artefact of it
being a small example and
of course i wanted to choose an example
that fits on one slide i didn't want to
have to draw all these nodes and edges
for a much larger example so
uh but you should rest assured that
these these red dots become
uh exponentially unlikely in in graphs
of cryptographic size
the other thing is there's some there's
some nodes for which there's self edges
or
where there won't be um the same number
of or the
the usual number of edges from a given
node to another node but again these
these stay as um a small finite number
so as
p goes up to cryptographic size these
behaviors go away
um and and we're not to be worried about
these
one more comment that's worth uh one
more thing that's worth commenting on is
that this
this super singular isogeny graph
behaves in the same way it did for
for two and three as it does as it'll
behave the same way for any given prime
so alice and bob could use l equals five
or l equals seven or any other prime
degree
to do their isogeny walks
but in this case we choose the we choose
two and three because those isogenes are
the most efficient
relatively speaking and we therefore
choose our primes
so that these isogenys uh are what we
say
uh are rational in the field so when we
do the computations
the the subgroups that we come across
have elements that are defined over over
uh the group of rational points over fp
squared
and therefore because our subgroups are
defined over f p squared
the inputs to values formulas are also
defined over f squared and therefore the
outputs of those formulas
or or all of the computation in those
formulas will be over fp squared so
we could work with five or seven even
over this prime but
to do so we'd have to find um torsion
points that are
that are defined over higher higher
fields than fp squared
um which would make the computations a
lot slower so that's why we deal with
two and three and
and and not with five or seven or any
other prime
but it's worth noting that these that
the graphs still exist for any prime
okay so now we're going to go step by
step through the protocol we're going to
we're going to uncover what was going on
with the with the picture on the first
slide
with the gif on the first slide so what
happens in the protocol is
alice and bob both start on a on a
public node so these parameters
in light blue here they're all public
for the for the whole world to see so
they're set up once and for all
at um at setup
and everybody who participates in the
protocol will will essentially start
from the same node and that's where
alice and bob start so we're going to
start at this node
87i plus 190 and
we're going to on alice's side she's
going to
walk on those edges in the two isogenic
graph and on bob's side he's going to
walk on the edges in the three isogeny
graph
what they also need is is points that
they can use
to find subgroups of a given order so
our prime here
as you saw on the previous slide was 2
to the 4
times 3 to the 3 minus 1 that 431
what that means is alice is going to
compute
two to the four isogenys or 16 isogenes
but she's going to compute them as four
chained two esogenies rather than just
one
one big 16 isogeny she's going to do it
most efficiently as a sequence of four
two isogenies on bob's side he's going
to compute three
three isogenies we like to we like to
choose our parameters such that two such
that alice's
um alice's two to the four is roughly
the same size as bob's three to the
three
and to to compute two to the four
exogenous what we need is
um kernel elements that are of order
sixteen
so alice is given two points
uh pa and qa in blue in the blue box
that are both of order 16 on this
starting curve
bob's given two points of order 27 on
the starting curve
and he uses these uh these basis points
to input a secret integer and as an
output of that
as an output he he gets a secret kernel
point of the order
of the misogyny that he's going to
compute
so this is how it works for alice she
takes those two points p
a and q a in the blue box and she
chooses a secret integer ka
somewhere between 0 and 16 or 0 and 15.
and that defines uh her whole secret
isogeny
so in this case we're going to assume
that alice chooses the the
secret 11
as her secret integer and she's going to
input that to compute the secret point s
sub
k so her secret point is 271i plus 79
that's the x coordinate
the one highlighted in red and that
defines her
destination node but to get there she's
going to compute that 16 isogeny
as a composition of four two isogenys
in bob's case his secret is going to be
the integer 2 somewhere between 0 and 26
that defines his his destination node
but he's going to get there
as a sequence of three three isogenies
so let's walk through alice's case we're
going to use those explicit formulas
that we saw
at the start and alice is going to start
here with a
with her secret point s of of order 16
she's going to compute them eight times
that point s
as a sequence of those doubling so she's
going to compute three-point doublings
to get a point uh of order two
and that defines the kernel of her first
two isogeny
which in putting that into values
formulas
takes her to the curve with j invariant
107.
so there she's computed phi sub zero
which is the first two isogeny in her
walk
she also uses those formulas we looked
at earlier to move
the point s through that two esogeny so
that
that that point can be moved through the
two misogyny and it becomes a point
of order eight on the new curve with
jane varian 107.
she's then going to multiply that point
by four
to get another point of order two but on
the new curve
and inputting that point of order two
into values formulas
on the curve with jane varian 107 gives
her a new isogeny
phi sub one that isogeny then takes her
to the
curve with jane variant 344i plus 190
she also moves the point phi naught of s
through
phi one and again its order decreases by
a factor of two so it's now got
order four on that point which means
alice only needs to
double it once more to get a point of
order two on this curve
and she uses that point of order two
inputs it into values formulas
to get the exogenous five sub two she
then
moves to the the curve that she's on now
and and moves her secret point through
five sub two
and its order again decreases by two and
now she's got
uh a point of order two already which
determines her final
isogeny phi sub three
so alice has computed these four two
isogenys and now she's landed on
uh the curve with j invariant 222i plus
and that is going to be alice's public
key so
she's going to keep those steps secret
and in and output just the jane variant
of
the the curve she landed on now uh
so this is this is a summary of what
she's done she's used a secret integer
somewhere in her um in her key space
from zero to fifteen
and that defined a sequence of steps
that she took in the two misogyny graph
and and she outputted this this uh
jane variant here on bob's side he's
going to do the same thing but but in
the three esogenic graphs so he's going
to start with his point
of order 27 he's going to use triplings
to multiply it down to be a point of
order three
that defines his first three isogeny
which moves him one node
he's then going to move that point uh
that original point of order 27 through
his first uh three osogony phi sub
naught
it's then going to be a point of order
nine on this second curve
he only needs to triple that once and
that gives him the kernel of his second
isogeny
uh five sub one
once he's on this second this second
image curve he
and he's moved that point of order uh
nine through his second three isogeny
he's now got a point of order three
on uh on this curve that defines his
final three isogeny
by sub two which takes him to his public
key
which will be this this j invariant 344i
plus 190. so alice and bob have both
completed the first
parts of their walk and bob's uh
bob's public key generation is
summarized the same way
and now what they need to do is send
each other their um their public keys so
that's
that's what we would do uh i guess in
the in the
uh the first stage of transactions in
tls or in any other protocol will
they'll they'll do their uh private
their public key generation in private
and then send the public keys over this
channel
and alice and bob will also
take each other's uh generator points
and have moved those through their
isogenies at the same time now this is a
technicality that i won't get into but
you can check the details in the paper
and in a later slide
for why they have to do this but they
not only have to
have to send their image curves but they
have to send the images of their of each
other's generator points
uh moved through these isogenys
okay so now once alice and bob exchange
their public keys
alice then starts a new walk from
where bob ended up so bob sent alice
that
that jane variant 344i plus 190 and
that's where alice will start with her
second walk
she uses the image points that bob sent
as well
but and and the same original secret
integer
to compute a kernel of a new 16 isogeny
now i'm not going to walk through the
the steps uh again this time because
it's exactly the same as
as during public key generation but
alice will again
compute four two isogenys exactly the
same way as she did before
to end up on a destination node
in this case it's the the node with j
variant 234
bob's going to do the same thing he's
going to start where alice finished
start at alice's public curve he's going
to
compute his his secret kernel the same
way
and then take three steps
to land at the same curve now as an
exercise for later
um and i've started it off here on on
the slide
but a good exercise to do is to convince
yourself that
um and to do this you have to use the
properties of of
of isogenes or of this um being a group
homomorphism
that alice and bob will land on the same
node in this graph
and so now they've done those walks
they've landed on the same node and
they've
used this this srdh protocol to come up
with the same
secret j value and notice that the
all the information the attacker has is
the curve that they both started on
the two curves that they sent over the
wire which we can they're public keys
which we can assume the attacker has as
well
and the attackers then tasked with the
with the problem of trying to figure out
where they both walked to the assumption
is that this is
indeed secure or hard for the attacker
to do
okay so now that we've seen how the
protocol
behaves over a toy example
it's time to have a look at what changes
between that toy example
and an example of of how srdh or psych
is used in the real world mathematically
there's not too many
there's not too many differences uh
between the way that the
the protocol works in our toy example we
saw that
alice took four two esogenies and bob
took three
three isogenies now we want the number
of the isogenies
that they can the number of possible 16
and 27 isogenes that they can take
to be a lot larger than that so that we
we have uh
we have a secure key space and and so
many uh possible random walks
that an attacker can't can't brute force
them all so we need to bump the
parameters up
but essentially as far as the
functionality goes that's the
really the only difference in between
the toy example that we've seen
in the webinar and between the examples
that are used
in the real world now when i say the
real world i'm referring to
four sets of parameters that have been
put forward by
uh uh myself and some researchers here
uh michael narig and patrick longer and
a big team of
uh fellow isogenists from around the
world that have submitted
the sidh uh or psych protocol
to the us's uh nist or national
institute of standards and technology
they're currently considering um
a number of post-quantum cryptographic
uh proposals for standardization and
psyc is the the one that's based on
misogyny or based on the protocol that
you've
you've just seen and and really the only
difference between
important i guess mathematical
difference between the toy example that
we've just walked through
and the examples we use in practice is
the number of isogenies that alice and
bob take
and the sizes of the primes that we that
we therefore have to use
so the smallest parameter set that we've
uh
put forward is when alice takes a
misogyny of size 2 to the 216 so she's
taking 216 to isogeny's
and bob's taking 137 three isogenies
in a graph that corresponds to a 434-bit
prime
so in that in that with a prime of size
of roughly size 2 to the 434 then
the number of nodes in that graph is
roughly p over 12 or
let's say 2 to 430 roughly speaking
so we've got a huge exponential number
of nodes
and we're working in this expander graph
and alice is taking 216
um two isogenies bob is taking 137 three
arsogenies but essentially
nothing changes but with the explicit
formulas that we saw and the
and the way that the uh protocol
functions
and what we're doing uh in practice the
only difference between
uh the raw protocol that you saw today
or sidh
and the protocol that's proposed in the
in the psych
specification is that we have to do one
more step or a couple more
additions to make sure that the protocol
is secure against active adversaries
we want the protocol to be secure in the
real world where adversaries can't
tamper with
alice and bob's public keys or they
can't use malicious public keys that
they've generated
to learn secret information about alice
and bob's secret isogenies
without actually attacking the hard
mathematical problem
we want these uh we want these protocols
to be
as secure as the the mathematical
problem on which they're based so in our
case we had to
transform um using some other
cryptographic techniques some well-known
and standard techniques to transform
this passively secure
protocol that we saw today into an
actively secure
uh key encapsulation mechanism but for
all of those details
and and for much more i encourage you to
check out the
uh the web page uh from our psych team
at psyc.org
or to play with the software and to
actually check out the
the post quantum uh uh a number of post
quantum proposals
uh made here and elsewhere you can go to
the nist website and check out the uh
the 26 candidates that are still in the
running um
for post quantum standardization uh at
the link that down there at the bottom
i'd like to thank you very much for your
attention and for and for
coming to this webinar and i'll uh now
be
sticking around to answer some of the
questions that were posed during the
webinar
um and if you're not in the live
broadcast today but you're looking at
this
uh later on or if your uh questions
don't get answered
now uh please feel free to to send
questions to my
uh to my email at craigco at
microsoft.com
um i'm always happy to to talk isogenies
with
budding and maybe futurists thanks
hello everyone thanks very much for
attending the
webinar on super singular isogyny
diffie-hellman and this
live q a my name's craig costello
and i'm here with my colleague michael
narig
so over the next 15 minutes we're going
to be answering some of the top
questions that have been submitted by
the audience
um apologies if we don't get to all of
them
we've just been selecting them as we go
some of some of them we've been
answering
uh live during the talk and some of them
we've been answering privately
but we've chosen some that are that are
really good that we're going to
um we're going to start answering
uh now so let's get started
all right hello everyone i'm michael so
i'm going to read the first question
um so the question is as follows are
there papers which prove that
encryptions based on isogenys are indeed
quantum resistant
i know this is currently not the case
for lattice-based encryption methods
yes that's a fantastic question um of
course we would
love to have a an iron-clad
mathematical proof that uh any
given scheme is uh resistant to quantum
attacks um unfortunately it's it's not
the case for
isogenes and it's not the case for any
of the um
any of the supposed post quantum
proposals but interestingly it's also
not the case for any of the uh classical
schemes that we already use
like rsa or um
uh elliptic curve cryptography based on
the discrete log problem
there is no proof that any of these
schemes
are even secure against uh classical
attacks so really what we do in
cryptography
if in the absence of being able to to
uh to find such a proof we
look for problems that stand the test of
time so we look for problems that we
believe are hard
and then we study them for years and
decades and then once hopefully little
or no progress has been made
trying to attack these problems
we start to get confidence that they are
secure
yeah there is no um proof that
any of the any of the schemes that we
already use are even secure against
classical
computers and all of these uh
quantum supposed post quantum
cryptography schemes
there we don't even have proof that uh
an iron-clad mathematical proof that
these that these proposals are secure
against
classical attacks let alone against
quantum attacks so
it could be that someone um takes
any of the quantum proposals lattices
isogenys
codes and goes home and attacks them
um using some new algorithm on a
classical computer
you know overnight and then that would
really shake up the field
uh but our many many decades of of
research
into uh a lot of these problems give us
confidence that those
that there are no classical attacks now
the difference between the uh
the supposed post-quantum secure
encryption and signature schemes that
we're looking at
and the classical schemes like rsa and
and finite fields and elliptic curves
is the only thing we we do know
is that there is a quantum attack
that breaks those schemes so um
we we do know with certainty that if a
large-scale quantum computer is built
it will be able to run shaw's algorithm
and
either factorize large integers or
solve the discrete log problem
in in a
polynomial time or um
poly logarithmic time and so what we do
know for sure is that that there is a
quantum attack against the schemes
like rsa and and classical elliptic
curve cryptography
which is why we've been forced to look
for other problems
that we believe are classically hard
just like those other ones
but for which we don't know of
a quantum attack even if a large-scale
quantum computer is built
so it just so happens that all of the
schemes that we
that we currently use to secure the
internet
we do know that there's a quantum
algorithm that already exists and if a
quantum computer
can run that algorithm those schemes
will be broken
but uh the the schemes that we're
currently looking at
for for post quantum security um
know there's no proof but we do believe
that they are both classically and
and uh quantumly hard
so i hope that that answers your
question
thank you and maybe we should answer the
next question
yep let's go to the next one so uh the
next question we
picked is the following we've got uh
well we've talked about
uh we've answered a few questions about
the numbers of qubits or the size of
quantum computers that are needed to
break
actual cryptosystems that are used right
now
so this question is related to that um
how many years are we away from a
quantum computer that will be able to
have 4 000 plus qubits
is it roughly 10 20 years away
well i'm gonna answer this this is a
very good question
and we all would like to know so uh some
people
that are rather sarcastic say oh it's
always 20 years away
um sort of yeah playing for the
the fact that people have tried for
several decades now and it doesn't seem
to be a lot of progress there although
there is
but i would say we we actually don't
really know
um some people who are very optimistic
and are working
in in the field trying to build uh
hardware that
and produce qubits say if all goes well
it could be in sort of seven years could
be in 10 years
i suppose the problem now is a lot of
hard
engineering questions that need to be
answered
and the real question is how how do
these qubits scale up so you might have
heard that
there are quantum computers with tens
of qubits 50 70 qubits but the question
is can we really scale this up
to thousands and note that the ones that
are
out there right now are numbers you read
in the
in the news they are usually um physical
qubits so
for for doing these algorithms
we would have to get to logical qubits
which might mean
any uh logical cubit might need up to
thousands of logical qubits to be stable
long enough so yeah sorry
i guess we can't really answer this
question
all right um so let's go to the next one
um question is how can we be sure that
security is not affected by giving
auxiliary opponents p
a p b q a and qb to the system
you want to answer that craig
yes michael thank you that's a that's a
fantastic question
uh those auxiliary points
okay so first of all i guess in
in relation to what i was saying before
um
we'd always like to be sure that
security is not affected by anything we
do
um but in this particular case
we're not sure um whether or not
the inclusion including these auxiliary
points
uh affects the security or
or the difficulty of the underlying hard
problem
at the moment the assumption is
um the the assumption is that
the isogeny problem using the parameters
that we
use for example in psyc using those
parameters
and including the auxiliary points uh
the the assumption is that the attacker
uh finds the problem no easier
using these auxiliary points than if
these auxiliary points weren't given
so that's just in relation to the
difficulty of
the underlying misogyny problem itself
we believe at the moment that um with
parameters that are balanced
and parameters that are chosen like the
ones in the psych specification
that these auxiliary points give the
attacker no
no more advantage than if the attacker
didn't have them at all but
uh there has been work um in multiple
directions that
shows that visa point these auxiliary
points can be problematic
the first which is um
really interesting is that these
auxiliary points were used
to give an active attack
um the original sidh protocol
in the case that uh one or one or both
of the parties wants to reuse
uh their private key so they want to
maybe
have a long-term static public key
then it was shown that um a
an active attack that uh
messes around with the auxiliary points
can can be used to gain information
uh using a very small number of protocol
interactions
with the party holding the the long-term
static key
um and in a very small number of uh
interactions the the party that's
tampering with these auxiliary points
can
uh recover the full private uh long-term
static key
and so this is the reason that the
srdh protocol uh the the simple one and
the one that you saw in the webinar
this is the reason that the srdh
protocol had to be modified from sidh
which is super singular or osogenous
diffie-hellman into psych which is super
singular isogenic key encapsulation
so what has to be done is
um these public sorry these auxiliary
points that are
part of the public key there's a check
that's done in psyc
that's not done in sidh that requires a
little more work but there's a check
that's done to make sure that these
points
um weren't tampered with in such a way
that the
the attacker can can recover
information about the the long term
static key so
to answer your question uh whether we
can be sure the security is not affected
well we we know that in sidh the
security is definitely affected
in the real world with with with regards
to
long-term static keys if if these points
are used
um and then in
a separate line of work so ignoring the
the
static reuse of keys there was work done
by
uh petite christophe petit that appeared
at uh asia crypt
uh a few years ago that gave
variance of the super singular misogyny
problem
um where the uh
inclusion of these auxiliary torsion
points leaked information about the
secret
um and this is kind of irrespective of
active
adversaries trying to attack a long-term
static key this is looking at
the difficulty of solving the underlying
uh hard problem
um petite showed that if you choose
parameters in a
in an unbalanced way where um alice's
secret isogeny is
uh that alice's secret prime power is a
lot larger than bob's secret prime power
if the parameters are unbalanced in that
way then
including these torsion points uh leaks
information about or information that
can be used to give a
different attack and recover the secret
so there's definitely two ways
that we know that the security is
affected with these auxiliary points
um but one of them is
one of them is based on parameters that
aren't actually used in practice so
the current belief is that if the
parameters are balanced then these
parameters give no
uh sorry these auxiliary points give no
additional help to the attacker
on solving the um the the raw
misogyny problem um that they'd be
forced to solve without them
and then uh in psych
the protocol is set up so as to verify
that the auxiliary points haven't been
tampered with
um which which renders those active
attacks
obsolete i hope that answers that
answers the question
all right thank you i think that also
answered another question
namely what exact problems led the
researchers to create psych after
um exactly what craig said at the end is
one of the reasons that was done so
another question
um i think very good and it look
it looks it looks like we have time for
one more question michael if you
if you have one okay there is
one yeah let me find it there it is
um the question is i'm lost about the
quantum properties that you are using in
your protocol i saw just mathematical
algebraic and geometric properties does
post-quantum refer just about computing
ah very good that's a great question
so yes the the idea is um
the idea in post-quantum cryptography is
that we're doing
uh operations and we're doing
cryptography
uh using classical computing
so we're not doing anything differently
as far as the
the cryptographers concerned the the the
honest parties that are using it to
um obtain security we're not doing
anything differently
um computationally than than we were
uh with with classical means like rsa
and ecc so
we're using classical computers to do
the cryptography
but the difference is the assumption is
that the attacker might have a quantum
computer
not that we need to use a quantum
computer to do the cryptography so
it's stuff uh this is all uh
cryptography that we can
we can do on our classical computers
today but the idea is that
this cryptography is secure both now
against
against classical uh against classical
attacks that we
that we know we could we could mount
today and it's secure
in the case if and when a quantum
computer is built
so we're not assuming that either alice
or bob needs to do
uh quantum operations they do everything
classically just like we do now
we're assuming that perhaps there's an
attacker
in the middle either now or in the
future that that has quantum computers
so we're only
hoping that the problem is hard um we're
hoping that the problem
is difficult to solve both classically
and quantumly but through the
cryptography from
a constructive standpoint we only need
classical operations the algebraic and
geometric
operations that you mentioned
and i hope that i hope that answers the
question is there anything else you'd
like to add there michael
no i think that was good right then i
think we're we're done
there's no more time okay we apologize
to everyone who
didn't get their question answered
yes absolutely
okay so thank you uh all very much for
attending today
we really appreciate uh your petition
and uh
your participation and your uh interest
in the subject
um and as i said earlier if you're
interested in learning more
there's a list of um resources in the
resource list to the right of your
screen
and yes thanks very much and have a
great day